We’re here at the office of Alex Martelli the
well-known Python programmer and author.
Let’s go in and talk to Alex.
In traditional Python the type well – type is strongly
connected to an object. An object’s type is
absolutely crucial to that object but it’s not
connected to the name. A name, a variable if you
want to call it that I would prefer to use the word
name can indicate any object whatsoever. There is
no constraint, a name is name is a name. Well if it
quacks like a duck and walks like a duck, it’s a duck.
Turns out – it was discovered a few years later that
there is actually a bird, which while it does like – is
morphologically indistinguishable from a duck but its
DNA analysis proved it’s a goose. So well, but the
point is that if you were a chef and needed to decide
how to cook it you'd probably want to use duck
recipes because it doesn’t have the amount of fat of
the goose so they don't really care about the DNA.
So, instead of checking the type of an object, the
concept was just make sure it has the methods with
the signatures that you need, which you can do
simply by trying and that leaves us to being easier to
ask for giving some permission, you try literally
within a try statement and if the signature is wrong,
or the name of the method is wrong, you get a
attribute error type error and catch it in an except clause and
either propagate the error or handle it appropriately.
Now, with the introduction of abstract-based classes,
the type becomes useful because it’s not anymore a
type in the sense of an implementation. It’s a type in
the sense of an abstraction. So, for example, there
is a numbers abstract base class and if you want to
verify that your argument is a number, actually
asking if it is an instance of number, it doesn’t
constraint at all the implementation, obviously, internally the
implementation of unbounded precision integer
versus a 32-bit float is going to be drastically
different, but they are both numbers, meaning they
both have greater than, less than, plus, minus,
times, and so on, so that kind of type check is now
respectable in Python. Not anything concrete but
checked for the abstraction that’s – it’s duck-typed
constraint, if you will. If it is a number then you’re
guaranteed of all a set of methods, operators and
signatures that you don’t have to check separately,
so look at it as a bundle of search operations.